the staff soweto marine of the beautiful beach
android team lock
I'm here today started a new series
of videos here for brazil it's today I will
talk a little bit about the byte design one
focused video series plus one aspect
android application design since
the design theme design first thing that
Do you know the android design?
we have a center is basically a
part of developer with 2 points with
design bar where you find a
series of guides good practice references
all about android application design
so you can go in there and get
within several sessions that we have
there to make your doubts know of good
practices and examples and everything else
It's good to spend a little bit on each
area that you can find in relation to
the design thing has a guide there that I
would spend if you're coming as
android now coming from the platform comes from
world or is starting to get
venture into the design part of
applications or even developer
wants to improve his skills there.
how to think nothing has developed a
application has been and has been
show an overview of all
components as it organizes them from
android
it's really worth seeing if you want
Do you want to be inspired by some
It's okay.
besides that we have to worry
with style is simply to do well
prettier make a chart also has
his own style involving style
surrounds the icon that you use
application involves the letter
colors are then in this area of
style you will find several branches
but several best practice tips for
you apply to your application as well
So if you want to participate, just
designing your application is legal the
your android crop looks like
platform is escaped with the platform
android is this is very important that
the user is not confused to use his
application for this we have from
of uai standards
including an example of how you can
implement that pattern
within your android application that is
very important so that you can
so it's giving all user support
so that it feels good to use your
software
We're going to have some things.
leaving the action a bar as you have
to use each of these types of
good component is also important
when you are going to design an application
that you know which are the main
components so that it can be applied and
combine your components
for example some things about lists
about tevez is under fragmente all vain
understand
using your share here of ours
our design with a guide a guide on
components that are in your
disposition
good but there intends to plan already
know the patterns saw what are the
components you want to draw is
make a mockup of your interface is cool
we have a session where I can download
resources to be able to compose this
interface is in your design software
favorite or even if you want
sketched on paper and then pass this
question the software is very interesting
to find various resources there
available for download, you are good and
But it's cool, I've read enough.
a little bit to feel some difficulty
No problem, we have some videos.
especially the last goal I'm here
google and 2013 that will address several
Today's themes go you can watch there
these videos anytime then
There is some doubt with a talk.
Did you find it interesting going there?
attend the lecture takes your question and
makes a top-of-the-line android app
well keep an eye on the
gailland we have in a number of branches that
have been developed to help you
we commented about the captive android
it's ok you do not get disconnected from there
It's only you can publish any
application in our store
but if you do one day they will get your
featured application is very important
follow these gases so you understand
tries in some test cases for you
to follow you go sailing
today dot com bar has distributed you and you
What are the tips of
test quality for tablet is very
It's important that you keep an eye out for this.
the staff and cited the first design
neighborhood where I want an overview for
you about where you will find the
android platform design features
I'll clear up your doubts and see
very interesting videos for the design
responsive about how you can design
the units of measurement within your
layout of your application good to see you
in the next